With every change comes loss.
I struggle to motivate myself sometimes.
But maybe I have to go 'cause,
I don't know what else there is the.
How the fuck did I end up in this situation?
Depression.
I can't concentrate at work.
And grief.
Screaming at the top of my lungs.
And sadness.
Screw you, I don't want any help,
I'm gonna kill myself.
After eight plus years and over 600 conversations,
I've compiled a fairly massive library of practical
information and timeless wisdom that
due to the nature of the internet
often gets lost in the seemingly endless feed
of new content released every single day.
And so I felt compelled to experiment with
a new episode format.
One that features a compilation of some of the best guests
I've had on the show in the past,
and centers around a single theme or subject matter.
This is the second deep dive.
The second masterclass episode we've done.
Part one about the microbiome was released back
in January.
And if you missed it,
you can find a link to that episode
in the description below.
But today, we're continuing the experiment with an extremely
important subject,
mental health.
All of the guests featured in this episode are either
experts in one of the various mental health fields,
or are individuals who have gleaned wisdom about
mental health through struggle.
These are truly some of the best,
most inspiring conversations I've had on this topic.
And you can find the full episodes for each in the
description below.
For too long,
talking about mental health has been a social taboo.
Many people have historically been too ashamed to admit they
need help and to seek it out.
And our society's lack of mental health awareness
and education has led to an epidemic of chronic stress
and severe loneliness,
as well as arise and things like suicide,
anxiety, depression,
and Alzheimer's disease and other forms of dementia.
And it is thus vital that we talk about it.
So to better understand mental health,
we begin today's show by talking about therapy
with Lori Gottlieb.
Lori is a Los Angeles based psychotherapist.
She's a journalist,
she's an author of the book
"Maybe You Should Talk to Someone."
And our conversation was about what happens when a therapist
experiences her own personal crisis and seeks help.
But it's also a broader conversation about mental wellbeing
in general,
which makes it the perfect place to start.
(bright music)
Do you think everybody should be in therapy?
Since the book came out,
everybody asks me that and--
Do they?
They do.
And I think it's interesting.
I'm not, you know,
I think everybody can benefit from therapy.
I don't think everybody needs to be in therapy.
But I do think this,
I think that so many times people come to therapy later than
they should,
meaning that we think about our physical wellbeing
different from our emotional wellbeing.
So if somebody feels like something is wrong
with their body,
like you're having chest pain,
you'll probably go to the cardiologist before you have a
massive heart attack.
But if somebody feels like,
oh, something doesn't feel right emotionally,
we tend to ignore it or minimize it.
"Well, I have a roof over my head and food on the table
so I don't really need help."
And what happens is,
they think that they can just make the
feelings go away or not pay attention to them.
But when you don't pay attention to feelings,
they become stronger.
And they come out in a behavior,
in a irritability or in a short temperedness
or in a self-defeating,
self-sabotaging way of being in the world, whatever it is,
or in an inability to sleep, whatever.
And so people then don't come to therapy until they're
having some kind of crisis.
And it's like, they're having an emotional heart attack.
I mean, there's no downside?
Well, time, money.
The biggest downside I think for people,
even though there are logistical problems
that are very real,
is that a lot of people kind of unconsciously know that if
they go to therapy,
they might need to make changes.
Right, yeah.
You know it's like
if I go to therapy.
who wants that?
Like I might need to do something different in my life.
I might need to be uncomfortable
and I don't wanna be uncomfortable.
So I'd rather just, you know,
just keep things the way they are,
status quo.
In the book I say,
"Insight is the booby prize of therapy,"
because you can have all the insight in the world like,
"Oh, now I understand why I keep picking those guys."
But if you don't make changes out in the world,
i.e. pick other guys, the insight is useless.
So many times people in couples therapy will say like,
"Oh, now I understand why I get really triggered by that,
when you do that."
You know, or, "And why I react that way."
But then they don't change anything.
"Well, you're wasting your time
if you're not gonna change anything.
So I think in therapy,
you have to be both vulnerable and accountable.
So you have to be vulnerable,
but you also have to be accountable for
what are you gonna do with the work that we're doing?
How are you gonna make some tangible changes in your
behavior when you leave here?
The change part is so hard.
Right, and people don't realize that they think,
"Oh, it's positive change.
So it should be easy because people want
something better to happen."
But with every change comes loss.
Yeah, the revelation feels like progress,
but it's actually not doing anything.
I mean, I've been sober a long time and you know,
the adage in 12-Step is
"Self knowledge will avail you nothing."
(Lori laughs)
Right!
And when people say to me like,
"Well, why do you think you were an alcoholic?
Like what happened when you're,"
And I've learned,
like it's interesting to explore that,
but I could spend all of my time trying to deconstruct that.
And it actually doesn't help, you know,
it doesn't inform how I'm gonna make decisions
going forward.
I have this toolbox now and I apply these tools to how I
make decisions and how I run things by other people that
have allowed me to maintain my sobriety and
become a more productive member of society.
So for me, it's about like the actionable tools.
And I think it is like,
it's so difficult for people to change.
And in my experience, in my own personal experience,
like I didn't change until I was in,
you know the pain of continuing on the path that I was on,
exceeded the fear of the unknown should I change.
So what is that like?
Like how do you get people short of having to have some,
cataclysm in their life to make those adjustments and
actually put your information and your insight
into forward motion.
There was something that my therapist said to me that I
write about in the book where he said, you know,
where I was like,
just feeling trapped by all of these sort of
external circumstances.
And I wasn't willing to make changes.
I wasn't willing to look at what I could do differently.
And he said, "You remind me of this cartoon.
And it's of this prisoner,
shaking the bars desperately trying to get out,
but on the right and the left, the bars are open."
And it was like, you know,
at first I thought,
"Oh, that's really cheesy."
But then I thought,
"Wait a minute, he's right."
Because so many of us would rather be the prisoners,
shaking the bars saying,
"I can't do anything about this."
We don't wanna look that it's open
on the right or the left.
'Cause then if we walk out and we go into the sunlight and
there are no bars and we're free,
with freedom comes responsibility.
And now we have to take responsibility for our lives.
We can't say, "Oh, the problem is, you know,
that I'm trapped here."
Now it's like,
anything that happens is I'm responsible for that.
And so change is hard for that reason.
You know, it's easier to feel trapped in the
whatever childhood drama that you're reenacting
than to actually do something different
where you might have to be responsible for your choices.
(bright music)
Taking responsibility for your mental health
is absolutely key.
And it can be a hard pill to swallow for the first time.
But ultimately it's really the only way forward if you wanna
make positive change in your life.
But what do we do when we just can't find the strength
within ourselves to work past our fear,
take responsibility for our failures and seek that help.
I mean, mental health disorders can literally impede our
decision-making processes just by nature of what they are
because they deal with the mind.
And how do you solve a problem of the mind when that same
mind created the problem in the first place?
Well, this next clip,
a section from my conversation with
author and journalist, Johann Hari,
addresses that very question.
Johann has written for the New York Times,
the Los Angeles Times,
and many other outlets.
He is also the author of two quite profound books,
"Chasing the Scream,"
and his more recent book, "Lost Connections"
which is a quite compelling
deep dive into the nature of depression
and its underlying causes.
My original conversation with Johann was a super interesting
exploration into those causes,
into those reasons,
and the cultural drivers behind both
addiction and depression,
as well as mental health in general.
What contributes to their malignancy,
what compel so many in this unhealthy direction,
and why they are so difficult to overcome.
I'm very excited to share this clip with you because
it moves the way we think about
our mental health journey away from being self-focused.
And instead, places it within the context of community,
as Johann shares the stories of a woman in pain,
a boy with ADHD,
a man in custody,
and the neighbors who saved their lives.
(bright music)
In the summer of 2011 on a big anonymous housing project
in Berlin,
a woman called Nuriye Cengiz climbed out of her wheelchair
and she put a sign in her window.
She lived in a ground floor apartment.
And the sign said something like,
"I got a notice saying I'm going to be evicted
from my apartment next Friday.
So next Thursday night, I'm going to kill myself."
No one knew this woman.
People start to knock on her door and they're like,
"Do you need any help?"
She said, "Screw you I don't want any help,
I'm gonna kill myself."
(somber music)
And outside the apartment,
some of the people who lived there,
they didn't know each other started chatting.
And one of them had this idea.
There's a big thoroughfare that goes into the central Berlin
that runs through this project.
It's called Kotti.
One of them had an idea,
:If we just block the street for a day on a Saturday,
there probably be a fuss,
the media will probably come,
they'll probably let Nuriye stay in her apartment.
Maybe there'll be some pressure for us to,
you know,
our rents to be kept down too and this disaster would stop."
And so they decided to do it.
They went and built a barricade in the middle of the road
and Nuriye was like,
"Well, I'm gonna kill myself anyway.
I might as well let them wheel me out of there."
It doesn't matter.
They wheel her out there and the media did come and they
interviewed Nuriye and the other residents,
a bit of fuss and
it gets to the end of the day and the police say,
"Okay, you've had your fun, take it down."
But the people that lived in Kotti said,
"Well, hang on a minute.
You haven't told Nuriye if she gets to stay.
And actually we want a rent freeze for our entire block.
It's this whole housing project.
So when you give us that,
we'll take it down."
But of course they knew the minute they left the barricade,
the police would just tear it down.
So people start to sign up to man the barricade, right?
Don't know each other.
Tania, in her tiny little miniskirt
was paired with Nuriye in her full hijab, right?
And these kinds of pairings were happening over CATI.
And first I think they had the Thursday night shift,
Tania and Nuriye are like,
(Hari scoffs)
"We got nothing to talk about, right?
What are we gonna talk about?"
It couldn't be more likely.
So they sit there through the night,
barely speaking first few times.
As the night went on, they started to talk.
They realized that there's something incredibly
powerful and common.
Nuriye told Tania something she'd never told anyone.
So she had come to Berlin when she was 16,
from a village in Turkey with her two young children.
And she was sent to raise enough money to send back for her
husband to come and join her.
After she'd been in Berlin for a year,
she got word from home that her husband had died.
And she told Tania that she'd always told people that he
died of a heart attack.
Actually he died of tuberculosis,
which was seen as like a disease of poverty.
They realized they had both been kind of children with
children themselves in this place
where they'd been very frightened.
They realized that's something really powerful and common,
these kind of pairings were happening all over the Kotti.
There was a young lad called Mehmet who kept being,
they kept nearly throwing him out of school.
They said had ADHD,
was paired with this grumpy old white guy
who said he didn't believe in direct action
'cause he loves style.
And in this case he'd make an exception.
They did a shift together.
The old white guy started helping Mehmet with his homework.
Mehmet started doing a lot better.
As one of the Muslim women there said to me,
"We all realized we had to take these small steps to
understand each other."
After the protest had been going on for about a year,
one day, a man arrived at Kotti.
He is in his early fifties,
he was called Tuncai.
And it's clear when you meet Tuncai
he's got some kind of cognitive difficulties,
he'd been living homeless,
but he also has an amazing energy about him.
Everyone immediately liked him.
And after he was there for two or three days,
that by this time they had actually turned that barricade
into a permanent structure in the street.
And with the roof and everything.
And they said,
"You know, you should start living here.
We don't want you to be homeless."
He started living there.
He became a much loved part of the CATI protest.
Nine months later,
one day the police came to inspect,
they'd to come and inspect every now and then.
And Tuncai doesn't like it when people argue,
he thought the police were arguing.
So he went to try to hug one of the officers.
They thought he was attacking them.
So they arrested him.
That was when it was discovered that Tuncai had been shut
away in a psychiatric hospital
often in a padded cell for 20 years.
He'd escaped one day,
lived on the streets for a few months
and then he found his way to Kotti.
So the police took him back to the psychiatric hospital
and he's put back in his cell,
at which point the entire CATI housing project
turned into a kind of,
"Free Tuncai Movement," right?
They descend on this psychiatric hospital.
I remember Uli canon-bomb one of the protestors
saying to them,
"You know, you don't love him.
He doesn't belong with you.
We love him, he belongs with us."
I remember thinking, you know,
how many of us if someone courted us away,
would have hundreds of people descending saying,
"No, we love this person."
The Bosnian writer Aleksandar Hemon said,
"Home is where people notice when you're there."
Right?
Lots of people are homeless in that sense.
And I remember thinking so clearly in Kotti,
think about how distressed these people were.
Nuriye was about to kill herself.
Mehmet kept being nearly thrown out of school,
they said he had ADHD.
Tuncai was shut away in a padded cell.
Loads of them are depressed and anxious.
These people did not need to be drugged most of them,
they needed to be together.
They needed to have a sense of meaning and purpose.
They needed a home.
(somber music)
I love that.
Once again,
you can find the links to these full conversations in the
description below.
Next up in this mental health deep dive is, Alexi Pappas.
I adore this woman.
She is truly extraordinary.
Not only is Alexi an Olympic athlete,
she's also a poet,
a writer, a filmmaker, and an author.
Her book is called "Bravey"
and it's a beautiful, lovely read.
I highly suggest everybody check it out.
I think most of us consider mental health to be chiefly
an emotional or a chemical issue.
We know mental disorders have to do with something
in our brains,
but we tend to think of them as
thoughts or feelings gone awry
as opposed to something physically broken.
A malady more akin to a scratch or a sprained ankle.
But in this next clip,
Alexi shares her experience of focusing on the physical side
of mental health.
And the way that subtle shift in perspective changed her
life and put her on the path toward healing.
(bright music)
So I was in total denial that I was sick
because I didn't understand that
your brain can get injured just like your knee.
I just, I didn't understand that.
And so I was of the mindset as I had always been in my life
that I needed to keep pressing forward
and fix all on my own,
whatever it was that I was feeling to the point where
I wasn't sleeping,
but I tried to force myself to sleep.
And you know, it's called falling asleep for a reason.
You have to let it, right?
Let it happen and--
You being a good type A athlete,
you're trying to know whirl everything into existence.
And then I started to have these even darker thoughts.
And that's when I felt like I understood my mom in a way
that I never wanted to understand her.
Like it's,
you have these thoughts that like,
you wanna die and
I don't think you really want to want to die,
but the thoughts say otherwise,
and that's when you're sick.
And it was terrifying because I always,
I've always been afraid my whole life for the moment
that that might happen to me.
And then when it did,
but before I understood that there was a way to get better,
I thought that that was just my fate.
That like, that was it now happened to me.
And because the narrative I was told about her was,
she just had to go,
like, she just,
she was so sick that she had to go.
And I was like,
"Well, I guess I'm so sick that maybe I have to go
'cause I don't know what else there is.
Wow!
(somber music)
That's so embarrassing honestly,
to share because I don't feel that way anymore,
but I didn't understand.
And I think it's sad that even someone who was susceptible
to these things, you know,
my family history was public, right?
There was no prehab, if you will,
if you wanna call, like,
if we wanna use this body comparison of the brain
is a body part.
I had no prehab.
I had no preparation to deal with this.
And it wasn't until my dad,
because of his experience with my mom,
made me get help that I met a doctor, Doctor Arpaia,
who told me very simply that I was sick and that my brain
had a scratch on it.
And that it could get injured like any other body part,
but it could also heal like any other body part,
and suddenly everything like
it literally turned around in a day.
Not I wasn't happy,
but I believed that I could be on a path to healing,
and that I could commit to it
just like I would in Olympic dream.
We are in a place where we can accept,
I think as a world that elite athletes and high-achievers
can have these mental injuries,
these mental illnesses.
But I think the most important thing now is like,
what do we do about them?
And that was something that I found.
I find that sometimes, you know,
we point fingers at the like,
the pinnacle institutions that we're chasing.
But actually I truly think that this kind of education or
shift has to happen much younger
and on a more universal level,
not just at those pinnacles.
So what would that look like if you were in charge
and could put those things in place?
Well, let's look at body,
the way we've approached the body and
like how that's progressed over the last,
let's say 10 years.
Like 10 years ago,
I don't think my dad or my friend's little sister would have
seen a PT for their body without having an injury,
meaning like regularly take care of their body.
And so just looking at that world,
we've come a long way to accepting that our body is
something not only elite athletes should take care of,
but everybody should take care of,
and that we should take care of it before it's a problem.
Ideally, if you are able to have that kind of support,
and it's not,
there's just like systems and you can get
that kind of help if you can and need it, right?
And I think with mental health,
the comparing it to healing an injury,
is so simple to me and makes so much sense.
So what it would look like to me is accepting honestly
that our brain is a body part and it can get injured.
And when it gets injured,
just like when we break our leg or feel something strange in
our leg,
we have no shame about sharing that something's off and we
get help and we know where to get help.
And it's either built into the system that we're in.
Like a team might have a physio,
they might have a psychologist too.
Or someone can refer you to their favorite physio or their
favorite psycho,
like there's just more accessibility,
just like there is in like the PT world.
And then we get that help.
And we are as kind to ourselves as we are hard on ourselves,
knowing that it's not gonna resolve overnight.
Like nobody is demanding that somebody's broken leg
heal tomorrow.
And so why are we demanding that somebody's depression
heal tomorrow?
Because it's uncomfortable for us to talk about, right?
We wanna pretend that it doesn't exist or there's shame or.
Right, because it's invisible.
But if we like think about it more like an injury,
like no one can see your torn hamstring either,
but they know that it's there if you say it
and they believe it's there.
So if we just see it as more of a physical injury,
which it is,
then I think it becomes a little less subjective
and a little more objective.
Right.
And in the meantime, just being told like,
you're gonna feel this way,
allows you to be in acceptance rather than
beating yourself up because you woke up again
and didn't feel good.
You don't have the secondary emotion of being offended
by the sadness as much.
You almost are like,
you wake up with the sadness like it's, you know,
I don't have a child,
but I think about like,
if a baby's crying and you're at the grocery store,
the baby's crying,
but you still gotta to get the milk, you know?
So I think that in that way sometimes where
you almost have a sense of humor about it,
or at least some levity to understand that it's there.
It will be there for a while.
And you're in the process of making it go away.
Actions change first,
then thoughts, then feelings.
And in that order.
And that was another life saving rule basically,
because what I've observed from my mom was that,
her caretakers were trying to force the feelings
and she was trying to force the feelings to change.
And we can't.
They follow our thoughts, which follow our actions.
Right?
(bright music)
Actions, then thoughts, then feelings.
Practical advice from somebody who has learned
that lesson firsthand.
But what kinds of actions should we take?
Therapy?
Physical therapy?
Reaching out to our neighbors?
And how do we know if those actions are the right ones?
Well, those questions lead directly
to the heart of this next conversation with
Doctor Rangan Chatterjee.
For those unfamiliar,
Doctor Chatterjee is a pioneer in the field of progressive
functional medicine,
widely regarded as one of the most influential doctors
in the UK.
Rangan is double board certified in internal medicine and
family medicine,
and holds an honors degree in immunology.
He also hosts the popular Feel Better Live More Podcast,
which I've appeared on twice,
and has been widely featured on
an array of prominent media outlets like the New York Times,
the BBC, Forbes, The Guardian,
Financial Times, and many others.
In his practice,
Doctor Chatterjee has found himself increasingly
treating patients on the daily who suffer
the downstream implications of
living with chronic stress
and other mental health disorders.
This in turn has given him the opportunity
to treat his patients in unconventional ways,
including a surprising approach you'll hear more right now.
(bright music)
One of the prescriptions I give people
and I don't particularly like the term prescription,
but one of the recommendations I make is to have a daily
dose of pleasure even just for five minutes.
Now, again, just to bring this to life,
I had a patient, 52 year old chap,
or maybe 53,
early fifties chap,
CFO of the local plastics company, right?
Again, comes in to see me.
He's worried,
"Doctor, do I have depression?
What's going on?
I struggle to motivate myself sometimes,
I can't concentrate at work.
I feel quite indifferent about my relationships,
what is going on?"
So as always,
I try to unpack different aspects of their lives.
"Do you like your job?"
"Yeah, not really.
You know, it's so so I have to do it
and I've got a family I need to provide for them."
I said, "Okay, fine,
How's your relationship with your wife?"
(Chatterjee sighs)
"You know what?
So so, you know, I don't really see her that much,
it's fine."
"Do you have any hobbies?"
"Doc, I don't have time for hobbies.
I'm busy.
I can't be late."
I said, "Okay, what about weekends?"
"Weekends, I've got to do the household chores.
I've got to take the kids to their classes.
I don't have time for hobbies."
So the prescription I gave him,
the recommendation I made some of the end of doing this.
And again, so that I don't get, (sighs)
not that it matters if I get criticized,
but just to be one person,
I did do the safety net thing that is required of me.
I didn't feel that he was an active suicide risk.
I didn't do all these sort of various things that I have to
do as a doctor.
I did check.
But ultimately what I felt was that he didn't have any
passion in his life, right?
And I said, "Look, I know you don't do any hobbies now.
Did you ever have a hobby?"
"Well, yeah, I guess,
you know, when I was a kid,
when I was a teenager,
I loved playing with train sets."
I said, "okay, great!
Do you have a train set at home?"
"I've got one at home.
It's in my attic I've not seen it for years."
I said, "Okay, look!
what I would love you to do when you go home tonight
is to get your train set out."
And you got a smirk on your face, right?
(group laughs)
Yeah.
I get it.
Hey, I have no judgment on people's hobbies.
I had a train set when I was a kid.
Well, I thought you were smirking on the fact that
he came in to see me with a problem
he was concerned about,
and my prescription was to get out his train sets.
Oh no, I'm with you on that.
Okay, you're with me on that, okay so.
So he, again, he agrees to go and do this.
So he goes away.
I don't see him then.
It is not uncommon in general practice in the UK for
you not to be able to follow up every single patient,
you just simply cannot do that.
So I got on with my job.
I was, you know, doing my thing.
Three months later,
I finished my morning clinic,
And then we have some go home visits in the UK where,
you know, normally after your morning clinic,
you will then have a list from reception of people
who may be elderly and firm
who can't get out to the practice and
you go and visit them at home to look after them.
So I was, I went to the car park,
to go to do my home visits and I bumped into his wife.
I said, "Hey, hey, look,
how's your husband getting on?"
She said, "Doc Chatterjee,
I feel like I've got the guy I'm married back again.
He comes home from work.
He's straight onto his train set.
He's on eBay all the time, trying to buy collector's items.
And he's subscribed to this
monthly collectors magazine now."
(Rich laughs)
Right?
So she's happy.
He's wearing his conductor hat in house.
Hey but she's happy,
but I still hadn't seen him, right?
Again, roughly three months later,
I'm just going through my clinic as usual.
And I see his name pop up and he has had some blood tests at
a Well Man Check.
And he's coming in to see me to go through them.
Welcoming him.
And before we go into the part of results,
I say, "Hey, look, how are you getting on?"
He says, "Doc, I feel like a different person.
Life is great."
I said, "Mommy's better.
I've got energy.
I said, "Okay, cool.
You know, how's your job?"
"Job, I love it, I love my job now."
"How's your relationship with your wife?"
"Really, really good.
I feel really close to her."
So just like that case,
I don't know how long we've been chatting for
maybe an hour ago.
Just like that's story about the kid who was feeling low
and who had a friendship deficiency,
did this guy have a mental health problem?
Sure, I think he had symptoms that would be consistent.
I could have made,
I could have labeled him and given him a diagnosis, right?
Or did this champ really have a deficiency of passion
in his life?
And the remarkable thing for me is
when that passion deficiency gets corrected.
Not only does he feel better in himself,
but everything else in his life starts to come back online.
The job that he couldn't stand before,
now he enjoys.
The relationship that was a bit tired
and he felt a bit indifferent about,
now he's feeling closer to his wife.
What generally happens is
that individual that came into your office would go into,
would either not seek help or in the event that that person
has the wherewithal to seek help,
would go to a practitioner.
And at least in the United States,
the system is set up wherein that doctor would only have
15 minutes with that person.
And it's a setup rigged to diagnose and prescribe,
and that person would leave with some kind of antidepressant
medication most likely,
and would then consider themselves depressed or clinically,
you know, having some kind of mental malady
without the tactile kind of real world
practical solution that you would implement
because you had the opportunity to provide that person with
a little bit more bandwidth.
I'm so passionate about this Rich,
because it's not as hard as we think it is.
Take small, small steps.
Find one thing you heard us talk about today
that resonates with you,
that you think you want to do.
Don't pick something that you don't wanna do.
Pick something that you do wanna do,
figure out how you can introduce a very small change
in that area consistently for the next few days.
And then re-assess,
and I bet you more often than not,
you gonna feel good about yourself.
Your identity is gonna change
'cause suddenly what happens then,
"Oh, I'm the kind of person who can make behavior change."
Right?
I've done that for the last five days.
That is the approach I have seen over and over again
work for people.
Please if you are struggling, take something from that,
put that into your practice.
Not next Monday, right?
Maybe put it into practice tomorrow.
(bright music)
I absolutely love that advice.
Put it into practice tomorrow.
Start small, start today even,
but does taking action with your mental health always have
to be so literal?
Is it possible that there are circumstances where the best
action you can take is to rest?
Well, that's the perspective of my next guest,
Caroline Burckle.
Caroline is a 2012 Olympian,
a 23 time all American swimmer,
an NCAA champion and an NCAA record holder.
One of my very favorite people.
I absolutely adore her.
She speaks about accepting our emotions,
vulnerability, mentorship,
honest communication,
and the potency latent and rest.
She has an amazing and powerful perspective.
And I can't wait for you to hear it.
(bright music)
Your feelings are valid.
They're not right or wrong.
They're not measured,
but learning how to use them constructively,
whether it's through sharing or understanding it,
communicating and being able to use those and move forward
with whatever that is,
is the key.
So I think we get wrapped up in not saying anything
'cause we're afraid to upset somebody,
but if there's somebody that you can share
how you feel with,
and that feels like a safe space for you,
feels safe to validate your feelings,
say, "It's okay you feel that way.
Let's get a little more information about that."
What is it that's really showing up there and really
understanding that the human's heart first,
they're gonna be able to perform better.
They're gonna be able to take that and use whatever that is
and turn it into something instructive.
Because I think we get stuck in our feelings
and we get stuck just thinking they don't matter,
brushing them away, pushing them away.
Really there's so much power in that.
There's so much information to be had in that.
That's beautiful,
regardless of if they're positive or negative.
You can take that,
remold it and turn it into an amazing performance,
a grade on a test, relationship with somebody,
with your family members,
extracurricular,
whatever it is that that person's wanting to do.
So that's something I like to say,
'cause I think we're shameful of our feelings.
We're shameful of what that means.
There's nothing wrong with that.
It's just information.
And I wish I would've known that.
(Caroline laughs)
I wish I would have been okay
knowing that however I felt was okay.
And that it wasn't,
there's nothing wrong with it.
It was just information.
Yeah, that's beautiful.
I think it's super important.
I feel like at least in the context of sport,
there has been a lot of progress and movement in the right
direction in terms of better understanding
that aspect of it.
I mean, I'm two generations older than you,
but when I see, you know,
the way that young athletes are being coached and mentored
now compared to what it was like when I was a kid, I mean,
that was a long time ago, but you know,
of course, much more,
there's much more to be gleaned and learned.
Totally, mental health is at the forefront right now.
People are caring about how people feel.
And I know this is an important thing to note is that,
you can be struggling and also be okay
with your performances.
You can admit that you're having a hard time
and also you'll still be okay.
You can still be and do great things.
I think there's
a misunderstanding there that if I,
again, back to that,
if I share that I'm depressed or having a hard time or
going through something,
then that means I'm not gonna--
It's gonna impinge on your performance, right?
I mean, that's the whole message
of the weight of gold, right?
It's like kind of a call to action to embrace
that aspect of what it means to be vulnerable
and to have the courage
to raise your hand and ask for help, you know?
The shrouding of it, the hiding of it,
because you're supposed to be,
this Bulletproof individual is not in service to anybody
and certainly not yourself.
And it's not complaining,
it's owning, it's self ownership.
You know, I think there's a difference between complaining.
I have some athletes say,
"Well, I don't wanna complain."
It's if we can shift it to it's self ownership,
then we can take that and use it,
just because you're having a hard time
have asked for help, et cetera,
doesn't mean you're all of a sudden gonna poorly.
It doesn't mean that you're not focusing on your swimming
or your baseball or whatever.
It means that you're doing something for your mental health,
which will then help that.
So it's a perspective shift.
Right, it does require some level
of mind-body integration though,
because you have to know when you are copping out like,
am I just wimping out here?
Or am I really in jeopardy where I need some outside help?
Like there is a difference.
And if you don't have that kind of intuition,
then you know,
you might be just, you know,
indulging in your laziness,
you know, instead of really being in peril.
But that's where great coaches and mentors come in,
because if somebody is vulnerable enough
to share whatever it is,
then they can catch that and be able to change that and turn
that into something.
Otherwise, they will just sit in their shit (chuckles)
so to speak
and, you know, let it go to shit and,
"well, whatever, I'm just copping out,"
You know?
So if they can articulate that,
communicate that information to whomever,
coach, mentor.
And this is where coaches and mentors can hear that,
taking that information and being able to help somebody,
being able to identify it without shame
and turn it into something better,
call them out on what it is in a nice way,
in a beautiful way,
like, "Hey, you're tough.
Let's make something out of this.
Like we're not gonna let this happen to you here."
That's where things can shift for the positive.
This is applicable outside of sport,
in the workplace,
like a boss-employee relationship,
or how management is structured so that
the work staff feels like they can raise certain issues.
And the manager is creating an environment
that's conducive to that.
I think ultimately leads to a much more effective,
healthy place to work or,
environment to excel as an athlete.
Absolutely.
And that is one of the most important things that I think
any organization can hold.
I mean, coaches, teams,
USA swimming,
is that if the standard is held there and if
people are all believing in whatever leadership there is,
and the leaders are able to develop these people,
athletes, employees, whatever it is,
and to a space of vulnerability openness and action
on what it is that we're doing,
not just talking about it and sitting around,
it's like actually acting on it.
Whether that action is,
"Let's sit with this for a minute."
Or that action is,
"Let's take action and do something right now."
Both of those things are beautiful.
That's how things develop.
And yeah, those are my greatest learnings from Mike DuBois.
He was just very much either like,
"Okay, let's now that we have that information,
let's either go this way and act on it immediately.
Or I'm gonna let you sit with that for a second.
I'm here right here next to you,
but I'm gonna let you sit with that for a second."
And like, knowing that I was like held in that space,
I think reflecting back,
that makes all the difference.
'Cause either ways an action.
You're empowering them either way.
They gotta figure it out on their own either way,
but it's the person that's gonna hold steady
and sturdy there that's holding a leadership standard.
(bright music)
This next segment is from one
of the most influential people in my life.
Perhaps more than any other single person
beyond my wife and my kids.
He has had without knowing it,
an unbelievably profound impact on my journey,
on my career,
and how I think about and pursue self-expression.
His name is Steven Pressfield.
He's a novelist,
he's a screenwriter.
And the guy behind some of the most important nonfiction
books on creativity that I've ever read,
including of course,
"The War of Art,"
which you've likely heard me talk about quite frequently
on the podcast,
because it impacted me so deeply.
But chief among his many messages on creativity,
is a concept he calls resistance,
negative self-talk is such a prevalent part
of our mental lives
and can often lead to shame spirals of anxiety,
depression, self sabotage,
and ultimately self-harm or suicidal ideation.
And Steven shares his experience of how to suit up and win
this war against the negative force of resistance.
I hold this man and his work
in the absolute highest regard,
can't thank him enough for the gift of his contributions.
His books literally changed my life and I can't wait to
share his wisdom with all of you right now.
(bright music)
Resistance is this negative force of self-sabotage
that will work against us
anytime we try to move from a lower level to a higher level,
ethically, morally, creatively.
If you have an idea for a book,
if you have an idea for a podcast,
if you have an idea for this studio or something that
you wanna do,
and I want to ask you about this Rich,
a voice will come into your head immediately
that will say,
"Who are you to put this thing together?
This has been done a million times and it's been done better
than you ever could do or ever would do.
You're too old.
You're too young, you're too fat.
You're too skinny, you don't have enough education.
You have too much education."
Et cetera, et cetera.
And that negative force is universal.
I can tell you from the thousands of emails I've got,
and not only is it universal,
but it's the same voice in all of our heads.
You know, it may be tailored a little bit to you or to me,
but it's the same voice.
And I was never aware of that.
And once I could sort of give a name to it,
then I could say,
"Okay, now I have something I can deal with.
How can I overcome this?
Can I develop habits that will help me overcome it?
Can I organize my day in such a way?
Can I change my mindset in such a way?"
And so, anyway,
that's kind of my definition of resistance.
Well, the first step seems to be
disassociating your identity from the resistance itself,
because I think what we all kind of do
is self identify with that, that is part of
who we are, right?
That's a great way
of putting it Richard, right?
I've never heard that before,
that's exactly it.
Well, you have talked about, you know,
this idea that exists outside of yourself, right?
If you're just thinking,
"Well, I can't do it."
This is me telling myself this,
as opposed to this external force that we can define as this
pernicious entity working at odds with
our effort to climb to that elevated place.
But what you just said, Richard is exactly right,
the disassociating,
this concept of resistance,
this fact of resistance from your own identity.
Like when we hear this voice in our head that says,
"You're not good enough, it's all been done,"
Et cetera, et cetera,
what makes that so powerful against us is
we think it's our own thoughts.
We think,
"Oh, that's me assessing the situation objectively."
But it's not.
It's this other siren voice,
this force that's just out there that's a fact of nature.
And once we can say,
"Oh, that's not me."
That kind of is the key to the whole thing.
And then again,
there is this force of resistance that when we try to ask
that question of ourselves,
you know, who am I,
what do I love?
What is my gift?
This force of resistance will try to stop us
from examining it.
It'll try to distract us.
It'll try to push us off in a shadow careers
or shadow activities or something that's not
in that way.
That's the war going and fighting that.
And you're fighting it against your own self,
against your own self-sabotage that's trying to stop you.
So that is, to me,
that's kind of
the coming into who you were already.
You already were that,
but you just didn't know it.
And through these actions,
you realize and you go,
"Wow, I had no idea I was gonna have a podcast."
I had no idea I was gonna be talking to 587 people
in writing,
"Finding Ultra" and "Finding Ultra Part II," you know?
I had no or whatever else is out there.
Right, but it's in the doing, right?
The waging of the war is action based, right?
Whereas I think a lot of people are,
maybe they're pursuing some self inquiry,
but it's an intellectual exercise and
they're sort of a waiting the epiphany.
Exactly, and I think for me,
I can tell you that I spent many years in that world
inside my head,
wasting my time.
It's like therapy.
It's like going there, you know?
(speaking gibberish)
and you know,
I think I've written like 20 books now,
which is kind of amazing to me since my first book came out
when I was 55, right?
That's so crazy.
It's absolutely true that before I wrote
any one of those books,
I had no clue that I was gonna write that book.
You know, not like it wasn't like I was sitting,
"Oh, I've got this whole magazine of books,"
like bullets in a magazine waiting to go.
I had no idea at all.
So but the point of that is
that we find out who we are by the works that we produce.
But until (chuckles)
until you actually start to,
once you start to act,
like I'm sure it's the same in ultra fitness
or anything like that.
Once you actually start,
then you start to discover things--
Right, the path unfolds in front of you.
It does.
Slowly, not you know--
Not easily.
Yeah, the idea of being that,
what paralyzes many is they wanna see
what that path looks like,
or at least, you know,
be able to forecast pretty far down the line before they
take the first step.
And it just doesn't work that way.
You have to take those steps,
not knowing and trust that the brick will get laid, right?
One step in front of you as you go.
Yeah, and it is scary.
I mean, it is the unknown that we're going through,
we're going into,
and it's scary.
There's no doubt about it.
Right.
(bright music)
Let's transition now to another facet of mental wellbeing.
What happens when we lose complete control over our ability
to reason, to register our surroundings,
to even recognize our loved ones or comprehend the
distinction between memory and reality.
I'm of course talking about dementia and more specifically
Alzheimer's disease.
No deep dive into mental health would be complete without
discussing one of the most prevalent and devastating
mental health disorders.
Alzheimer's is a disease that currently afflicts over
47 million people worldwide right now.
And that stat amazingly is predicted to triple by 2050.
But it's especially important to talk about Alzheimer's in
light of the work of my next guests,
Ayesha and Dean Sherzai are husband and wife
neurology team.
Together, they co-direct the Alzheimer's Prevention Program
at Loma Linda University,
where they study all things brain health
with a very specific focus on lifestyle interventions
that can prevent cognitive decline and neuro-degeneration.
Their work is proving that Alzheimer's is preventable and
even reversible in 90% of cases,
this clip is absolutely mind blowing,
and I hope that it can serve as life-changing information
for you if you or someone you love is affected
by this horrible disease.
(bright music)
I mean, we're talking about
every other disease in decline,
pretty much every other disease or death from every other
disease in decline,
yet mortality and death from Alzheimer's in just the
last 10 years has grown more than 80%.
Part of that is because we're aging society.
We're doing better with the,
yeah, we have more diabetes,
we have more obesity.
We have more of all these other diseases,
but we're surviving them with machines, with surgeries,
with these catheters, all these things we're living past,
what we would have lived before.
Are we can survive diseases like
that used to,
We can survive.
Used to kill us.
Absolutely.
Exactly.
But when it comes to what's left behind is our brain.
At the end of the day, we're left with our brain.
And that's the cumulative problems over 50, 60 years
that actually end up in being Alzheimer's at the end
or dementia in general Alzheimer's.
And that's where we bring the new kind of conversation.
So When you began this journey,
15 some odd years ago,
I would imagine, you know,
like you kind of alluded to earlier,
your colleagues are like,
"This is career suicide.
What are you doing?
You're gonna start looking at,
you know, lifestyle medicine for this."
And so I think it would make sense to kind of explain,
or at least talk through some of the myths and the
misconceptions about this disease,
particularly this notion that it's a purely
genetic situation.
Like if you have the gene,
this is what's gonna happen and there's nothing you can
do about it.
Right.
And that has been the misunderstanding for such a long time.
And there are a few genes in Alzheimer's disease,
maybe less than 5% of the genes that,
completely determine
whether somebody gets Alzheimer's or not.
As a matter of fact, if you have those genes,
you're definitely going to get it.
But even for those,
you can push it off for a very long time,
for the rest of them, for, you know,
the 95 plus percent of the genotypes,
it's quite clear that what you do in your life,
the type of food that you eat,
whether you exercise or not,
or the level of stress that you have
determine whether you're going to get the disease in
your early sixties or in your late nineties.
Right, right.
So the magnitude of how these genes are expressed is
contingent upon what you're eating and how you're moving and
how you're living your life.
Absolutely.
Completely, completely.
If you take care of your brain,
you've taken care of all the body,
because now this thing that we're trying to create,
living mind kind,
it's about the mind.
Mindful living,
and so this affects the totality of your body.
For brain, it's something more than that
because here you have emotions as well.
You have motivation,
you have all this.
So one of the elements of our book is not just saying,
"This is bad, and this is good,"
but where we have failed people is we just throw it at them
without giving them the tools of how to apply it
to their life.
So mindful living is the unique thing about our book,
more than even the science, and so.
And it's a vicious cycle.
If you feel good, you know,
based on the good neuro-chemicals
being produced appropriately,
if you take care of your brain,
and if you have a healthy mind that
owning that mindfulness
in your life and applying it on a regular basis
can help you take better care of yourself.
So there you go,
you have a healthy brain,
you have the tools to take care of your heart and the rest
of your body.
Right, and everything follows.
(overlapping chatter)
Depression, recently papers came several.
I mean, whenever as a science,
we don't say paper came in,
a paper means nothing.
It has to be multiple and validated.
Lots of papers say that
one of the major causes of depression,
inflammation.
Yeah.
So it's keeps coming back.
Yeah, we keep slipping.
I call it logic slip.
And a lot of times when you have debates,
you keep building these logical sequence and you work past
the fallacies and everything,
and then it slips again.
That's what's happening in nutrition and lifestyle
and you make the case.
I mean, the case for diet has been made over and over again.
And then all of a sudden slipping it.
Now we know inflammation and all these things actually even
affect the depression, anxiety,
everything, all of these diseases.
Right, you you can't extract
one thing from the other, right?
And it seems like
the advent of functional medicine,
lifestyle medicine is growing
and people are starting to embrace this idea that
it's not just one treatment protocol that we have to kind of
look at a person in a holistic way and treat them,
all the way down to
how they interact with their family members and at work.
And what's their relationship with their boss.
And, you know,
all of that stuff is crucial to kind of
solving this problem.
(bright music)
We have to look at a person in a holistic way,
but can we also look at the totality of our emotions,
the joys as well as the sorrows in a holistic way?
Is there anything we can learn from negative emotions and
mental health struggles?
Is there a way to find healing through reframing our
perspective on depression,
committing to total honesty about
our feelings and exercising vulnerability?
Well, Kundalini Yoga master,
and dear friend Guru Singh addresses all of those questions
in the following clip.
I encourage you to spend some time with this next one
and really absorb what he has to say.
It's a simple perspective shift,
but it is by no means easy to do.
Please enjoy in taking the wisdom of Guru Singh.
(bright music)
Then I think the pace,
the accelerated pace with which
culture, society,
is advancing, is changing,
is evolving,
is so outpacing our evolutionary
ability to adapt.
You know, we're still,
(overlapping chatter)
We're evolutionarily, you know,
built into our GNA into our genetic code
is a life that looks like whatever's going on in the,
you know,
the indigenous tribes of Africa.
And if you go to those places,
you always hear these stories.
"Oh, I went to India,
I went to Peru, I went,"
wherever it is.
And people who spend time with cultures that are relatively
immunized from the way that we live,
realize how much happier they are,
how much more connected they are,
how much more communal they are.
And content,
they have all of these things
that we're trying so desperately
to build into our own lives,
but which continue to elude us
because the very things that contribute
to that which we seek,
we've decided are either optional or not important.
Think about this,
depression has a value because when you're depressed,
you can go into some pretty deep places,
some pretty dark places.
And when you go into those places with the sense of,
"Let me explore," rather than,
"Let me feel horrible."
Those deep places can confine character,
confined parts of your being that are able to come forward.
There would never be noticed
if you were just giddy and happy all the time.
And the same thing with good grief, right?
Grieving, sadness, grief.
You know, these are also valuable moments.
So depression and grief and sadness,
are all things that when they come upon us,
we should go into fully,
but giving ourselves the space,
I'm gonna take a sick day because I'm feeling really sad.
And let me go into this sadness,
let me process this sadness.
Let me gain the messaging from this sadness,
just as if I was to take a sick day because
I've got the flu.
These are things that need to be viewed within the
individual life.
But the fact is,
is that diving into that,
that depression,
diving into that sadness and taking off the mask
and admitting it and saying,
"you know, I'm not looking for anything from you,
but I just got to say, you know,
what's happening in the world today,
or what's happening in my world today,
or what just happened in my home or whatever,
I'm not feeling good."
Or you could even say,
"If it's chronic, you know what?
I haven't felt good for 10 years."
And then all of a sudden,
let's go with it.
And then the cocktail party
goes silent.
(Rich laughs)
Yeah,
but you know, to heck with a cocktail party,
you know, let's be honest.
This is the thing.
I mean, I think it's terrifying for people.
If I admit that I'm not feeling good.
You know, what are people gonna think of me?
And I think that goes right back into this discussion around
shame and around vulnerability.
We're taught to comport ourself in a certain way
to navigate social circles in a manner
that will allow us to maintain
that trajectory of upward mobility
and to act in contravention of that
is to put at risk everything that
you've staked your life upon,
which provokes fear.
And that sense of shame is the ultimate prophylactic against
behaving in a way that actually would contribute
to greater health.
If we're ashamed about something,
the most terrifying thing would be to shed light on it,
to expose that in a vulnerable way to another human being,
the stakes can be very high for people.
But ultimately placing that into, you know,
a social setting in which it can be discussed
in a mature way, is the path to healing,
but it requires us to be vulnerable and we're not raised to
be vulnerable.
But I think that vulnerability,
that willingness to be vulnerable is the ultimate courage.
And when you can expose that which you're ashamed of
from a place of wanting to heal it,
asking for help,
allowing yourself to be vulnerable
requires a tremendous amount of courage.
(bright music)
Okay, so far in this deep dive,
we've covered so many aspects of mental health,
but I would really be remiss if we failed to cover PTSD,
a very serious affliction obviously
that impacts somewhere between 11 to 20% of all
Iraq War Veterans,
and 30% of Vietnam Vets,
something like 22 veterans take their own lives
every single day,
which is just horrifically insane.
War of course takes its toll,
but I think it's incumbent upon all of us
to better address the undeniably significant psychological
effects that we ask our brave men and women to endure.
There is a path to healing and
we're gonna discuss that path.
Our steward for that exploration is Iraq War Combat Veteran,
Sara Lee.
Sara is a former army sergeant who served eight years
in the military,
including a 14 month deployment to Iraq in 2004
for Operation Iraqi Freedom II.
Her story is heartbreaking.
Upon returning home from deployment,
she basically endured one thing after another,
until she found herself a hundred pounds overweight
and descending into this very dark depression that became
so bleak that in April, 2017,
she very nearly took her own life.
And the absolutely bone chilling part about our conversation
is the fact that the very same day,
in fact, at the exact same time
that Sarah and I recorded this conversation,
which was a fair while ago,
just 13 miles away from us,
another young military veteran
in a fit of depression and despair
pulled out a 45 caliber semi-automatic pistol
with a laser sight,
and opened fire on a crowd of mostly 20 somethings,
ultimately killing 12 people before
fatally shooting himself.
And I think the confluence of these two events really
underscores and emphasizes the severe gravity
of our mental health epidemic.
Sarah thankfully found a way towards healing,
which as you'll hear in a moment,
all began with a bicycle.
(bright music)
So what was the lowest moment?
It was the day right before I bought my bicycle,
right before I bought the bicycle.
And I just, I knew after the surgery I'd be limited,
my neck had gotten bad.
My knees, I felt like I'd have to start all over.
I had no muscle base anymore for,
'cause that's when I'm not really in pain is when I have the
muscle in place.
And I just felt like I just didn't even,
I'm just not capable of anything anymore.
Yeah, was it depression?
Was there suicidal ideation?
Was there, you know,
what was the mindset?
Yes, I definitely was.
I guess I can say that
I was fantasizing about it and that evening was probably the
closest I'd ever come in my head to do an attempt.
I had an attempted suicide prior and
I just decided that I can't do that to my lucked out,
very loving family.
And I couldn't do that to my parents, so.
But even in that moment,
you didn't have friends or family around that
had a sense that you were going sideways.
No, no one really knew I was going through any of this
until I made a Facebook post about it.
And basically I said a lot of the things
that I've said here,
I expressed and explained that
since getting out of the military,
it feels like I've kind of lived a whole lifetime and
there's really nothing left to do.
That's kind of where I'd arrived in my mind.
I said that I've had these
nagging, annoying thoughts that
I'm really only living life to fulfill
some sort of obligation to the people that love me
and nothing more.
And I felt so guilty about saying that because everybody
that cares for me is probably like, you know,
"I thought she has a great time with me.
I could have done or said something differently."
And usually people end up thinking that way
after it's too late,
that's why I decided I needed to get this post out there.
And the reason I waited is because,
the bike trip was already in motion and I was like,
"Here's what I'm doing about it."
'Cause I didn't wanna just come out and say,
all the negatives.
All right okay, gotcha.
So you went public with it after you were already
kind of well into the solution.
I made that post and then I described
the plan for the journey and the support was unbelievable.
It wasn't like I expected it would be like private messages,
you know, "You're in my thoughts and
if there's anything I can do,"
you know, stuff like that,
people were like,
"This is amazing, I'm sharing this."
And maybe other veterans will kind of decide to do something
about it or just try to take back some of that purpose
for themselves.
Try to take on a challenge.
Well, so when you're in that moment,
you were in that darkest,
you know, that darkest moment.
What was it that clicked in side of you to do something
about it?
Like, take me from that moment
to the moment of deciding that
you're gonna get a bike and ride a bike and how this
whole ride came together.
Yes, I'd been planning the trip with a friend
I met through a mutual friend in Marine and we talked about,
but I hadn't purchased my bicycle yet.
And I was still really struggling and on the fence about,
you know, actually going through with it.
And I had an evening where I just,
I just tend to stare at the wall sometimes for a while and
think about big stuff or just anything really.
And I get kind of lost in some of that.
And I think I just convinced myself that I think people
would be okay.
And that basically it goes back to coming home
without my friend,
just, I don't know if I deserve to be here
and I'm not even taking
advantage of the life that has been gifted to me because of
someone else's sacrifice.
And it just really nausea at me.
It still does,
but I had kind of a game plan for if I had gone through
with taking my life and everything.
And it was a bit elaborate,
but it was kind of like the least,
one of the maybe the least shocking kind of ways.
I just didn't wanna hurt anyone or scar anybody,
you know?
So that night I was right there.
I'll say I was like right there and
I ended up just falling asleep.
And so the next day I was like,
"That's it, I can't do one more night like that.
I'm not gonna get through it.
I'm not gonna get through it."
So I literally just woke up and went and purchased
my bicycle the next day.
You went right to the bike store.
Yes.
And you had had, so the plan was,
the plan was already in motion to do a ride prior to that.
You just hadn't taken any action on it yet.
Right, purchasing the bicycle was
like the decision maker.
And had you been a cyclist,
like had you ridden a bike before?
No, not, well,
not since ninth grade.
Other than just being a kid or in the
neighborhood or whatever.
No, then no,
grade school was the last time I rode a bicycle.
So, but it comes right back.
It really does.
I took the bicycle.
(laughs) Adage is true.
Once you learn how to ride a bike.
Like riding a bike,
and everyone would say it and I'd be like,
"Ha ha."
And then I got on it and I'm like,
"Okay, that's why that exists.
It really does come right back!"
So when you think back on this bike ride,
is it the adventure aspect of it?
Is it the challenge aspect of doing something that was very
difficult and maybe you thought you couldn't do?
Was it the connecting with the veterans
and just Americans in general?
What aspect of that do you think has been the most impactful
on your healing process?
Or is it just all of those things together?
Well, the easy answer would,
be all of it and the truest answer
would be all of it, but.
(Sarah sighs)
I really feel that I wasn't okay.
And I'm really no good to anyone unless I'm good to go.
And this, the reconnecting,
like you said, with your body,
with nature and with people,
I think it just really takes all three of those things.
That's why I wanna do this next step.
And I've felt like my life was changed forever
in a really good way from East to West.
I just, I like to relive some of the days randomly
throughout my day.
And I just,
I wanna facilitate like smaller versions
of what I felt like, you know,
experienced firsthand,
this healing.
I wanna help other veterans get a sense of that
or at least introduce them to it.
(bright music)
Well, well, well,
here we are final clip and I can think of no better way
to close out this deep dive
than with this story of Hakim Tafari.
Hakim is quite the extraordinary human.
He's an ambassador of running culture and mindfulness.
He's a master of many,
a martial art from Kung Fu to Tai Chi.
He's also an herbalist, a massage therapist,
a vegan, a father,
and a practitioner of many,
a spiritual path from Buddhism to Taoism
and essentially everything in between.
He speaks in this final clip about the light
at the end of darkness.
And my desire is that,
if you're listening to this because
you're struggling with anxiety or depression
or any other mental health malady,
that you find comfort, that you find healing,
and that you find hope in Hakim's story.
(bright music)
You need something.
Come to the temple.
At the time, I didn't know what the temple was.
She said, "Come to the temple."
I was like, "Okay."
So I drive up there and I've got this
big Springfield 45 next to me.
And at the time I just got off the phone with my ex,
we had just gone into a major argument.
I'm literally just like shaking uncontrollably.
And I'm like,
"Do I just do it right now?"
I'm looking at the gun.
I'm in front of the temple.
(suspenseful music)
And then I'm like, "All right, fuck it.
I'm gonna go do whatever this fucking thing is.
I don't know what I'm gonna get into,
but I'm gonna do it."
That could have been my last day on the earth.
And instead I chose to sit in front of a wall in silence
for an hour and a half.
When I was literally crawling on the bottom like,
I don't know if I can make it.
That was kind of like the ladder that was like,
"Yes, you can."
(bright music)
There's so much beauty in suffering.
There so much beauty in suffering.
And I know it sounds so,
it's not cliche,
but it's people are like scratching their head.
How can you suffer?
How can there be beauty in suffering?
When you go through the suffering that a lot of us have
that have been on his show,
that have become successful,
is because when you go through that suffering,
you go through such a darkness,
you go through such a bottom feeder
kind of exposure that
you learn to have gratitude for the smallest thing,
the smallest thing.
And when I think about the times when
I didn't think that I was gonna really make it
out of that space.
(somber music)
There were times Rich when,
I would be in the car park of whole foods,
like crying,
crying my heart out,
screaming at the top of my lungs,
looking around like,
how the fuck did I end up in this situation?
Because mental health and suicide is so big.
And I know in this day and age
it's being amplified and people are talking about it but,
(somber music)
when you hit a certain level of
suffering and you think there is nothing else,
(somber music continues)
you can look back at these times in that darkness
and be like,
"Man, if I didn't know the depths
and the levels of darkness,
I wouldn't be able to enjoy this moment right now."
(somber music)
That concludes today's deep dive into mental health.
I really hope that you not only enjoyed it,
but found it helpful.
In closing, if you are struggling,
please, please raise your hand and reach out for help.
For a catalog of helpline resources,
you can visit the website for the
National Alliance on Mental Illness
at nami.org.
And if you're experiencing suicidal ideation,
I encourage you to call the suicide prevention hotline
at 1-800-273-TALK.
Links to these resources can be found in the
description below and in the show notes
on the episode page at richroll.com
If you found today's video valuable,
please subscribe to my channel and I'll see you in a few
days with another great episode,
Peace!
Namaste!